Bố nội vụ vừa có công văn đến nghĩ các sở nội vụ địa phương
hình chương thành lập các đoàn điều tra tay nạn là động cấp tình theo đúng quy định của lợt Anpuan
về sinh là động và hướng sẫn hiện hành.
Theo đó, sở nội vụ có chết giảm gia quy định thành lập đoàn điều tra khí xảy ra tay nạn là động nghiêm trọng sinh địa bàn.
Thành phần đoàn bao gồm đại dựng phòng truyên muang thuộc sở, đại dựng xử ý tế,
linh đoàn là động tình và các thình phân khác nếu cần thiết.
Độ thái này, nằm tăng kưởng công tác quả liền nhận nước trong lĩnh vực Anpuan là động,
sau khi nhiều địa phương tình hành sắp sếp lại tổ chức bộ mái,
trên tự vô hình thành chà xang chức năng kìm chà truyên này.
Năm 20, 2020, cả nước viện hơn tắm nghiên hai chăm vụ tên nạn là động,
làm trên tắm nghiên bố chăm bệ mối vui bị nạn và bệ chăm hai mấy bệnh vui thiệt mạng,
với thiệt thại hàng chục nghiên bị đồng.
Những nền nghị có dùi gió cao vùng khai khoáng, xây dự,
đến kiên và sản xuất bật liệu xây dự.
Bộ nội vụ nhìn mạng, việc điều tra tài nạn là động kì thời,
đúng quy định là cơ sở để giúp kinh nghiệp,
sử lý trách nhiệm và tăng kưởng vụ của các phòng người tại nước làm việc.